in lda leveneur baussillon j'ai 42 ans
je suis conseillère départementale du
canton 13 à saint joseph je suis
également conseillère communautaire à la
casud et adjointe à la culture et à la
structuration du pôle vincendo langevin
à saint joseph
j'ai grandi et je vis avec ma famille à
vincendo avant de rejoindre l'équipe
municipale et patrick lebreton en 2014
je m'engageais en milieu associatif au
coeur des quartiers aux côtés des
familles en qualité d'animatrice de la
vie sociale du lien social j'ai dirigé
également un équipement culturel et
social dans l'est en qualité de
conseillère départementale avec mon
collègue harry mussard nous porteront
haut les valeurs de progrès social et la
voix des saint joséphois
en matière de politique agricole nous
souhaitons maintenir le partenariat de
qualité autour de la charte agricole il
faut aussi poursuivre la réalisation et
la réhabilitation des voiries agricole
est l'enjeu majeur et l'aménagement de
l'eau dans les eaux donc l'irrigation
des terres agricoles sur le secteur de
la crète et de bézaves nos routes
départementales ont besoin également
d'aménagement en matière de sécurisation
et d'amélioration du confort routier et
il faut aussi noter l'impact des eaux
pluviales à conjuguer département
commune aux abords de ces routes
départementales seront attentifs à
l'engagement du département auprès des
collégiens par les moyens dédiés au sein
des collèges et pour ce qui est du pacte
de solidarité territoriale
il s'inscrira en solidarité de l'anc
l'engagement communal au plus près des
saint joséphois par le biais d'
équipements de proximité du lien social
et en terme d' espaces sportifs de
loisirs et culturelles
nous faisons face depuis deux ans à une
grave crise sanitaire qui
impacte davantage la situation sociale
et économique à la réunion j'attends du
département plus de vigilance dans la
lutte contre les inégalités sociales je
souhaite aussi un conseil départemental
plus près des acteurs associatifs
engagés notamment dans l'accompagnement
social dans l'aide alimentaire dans les
actions d'éducation prévention santé
dans l'aide à la parentalité ou encore
au plus près des associations qui
agissent dans la lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales
il me semble aussi important que le
département améliore le dispositif
d'accompagnement des aides sociales
pour ce qui est des moyens financiers et
pour ce qui est aussi des délais de
réponse et puis il ya aussi ces
situations si particulières qui
nécessitent des réponses très
particulière c'est ce qui m'interpelle
davantage au niveau du conseil
départemental enfin je serai très
attentive à l'engagement et aux
propositions formulées par le conseil
départemental dans le cadre de la
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique il s'agit d'apporter les
meilleures réponses pour un mieux vivre
et pour un mieux être individuel et
ensemble à la réunion dans le cadre de
cette démarche concertée état région
département interco et communes enfin je
suis de celles qui souhaitent travailler
à partir des spécificités réunionnaises
de l'identité réunionnaise certes les
problématiques mais aussi davantage les
potentiel à développer
pour un mieux vivre et un mieux-être à
la réunion